meine zuschauer lieben ist die
kommentare zu shrek kommt am meisten
geht es um eine neun jahre mein
schönster hell und dass ich so witzig
bin aber eine sache lässt sie nicht los
zwiebeln schneidet in den letzten zwei
jahren noch nicht mitbekommen hat
richtig kochen videos auf youtube machst
du und da kann es schon mal vorkommen
dass sich eine zwiebel schneiden muss
und leider gehöre ich zu diesen leuten
bei dem die tränen sehr sehr schnell
oder straight einige von meinen
zuschauern wenn ich kriege unter jedem
video live hacks tipps wie man zwiebeln
schneidet ohne tränen zu bekommen und in
der zeit haben sich sehr viele sehr
viele tipps angesagt
und jetzt fragt ihr euch zu recht aber
wenn es jetzt ein video machen indem du
zwiebeln schneidest gar dem reit- und
bevor jetzt abschalten wollen weil ihr
euch denkt nein das ist ja langweilig
mich da gehe ich lieber aufwendig
beautycase und guck mal ich an
schwangerschaftswochen sie ist bleibt
hier denn die tiefsten wirklich kreativ
und ich hoffe ich werde einige davon
vielleicht in zukunft an anwenden damit
diese menschen die jedes mal schreiben
vanessa mach bitte dass ihre ruhe finden
also lasst uns herausfinden welcher der
beste zwiebel heck aller zeiten ist
wenn du trieben schneidest musst du
drinnen und währenddessen voll mit
wasser machen
[Musik]
wenn die zwiebeln schneiden musste sie
eine schwimmbrille und dann kommt das
nicht in die augen für die wissenschaft
mir ist meine augen raus gesorgt dies
ist auch stark
das müsste jetzt funktionieren
foto oh mein gott meine augen sind total
drachen spüren nicht ersticken
hast du eigentlich mein absolut
bestanden
[Musik]
taucherbrille und wasser im mund meine
brille blockt immer so auf
[Musik]
die kombination bringt nichts nur die
tore wurde es besser und ich bin
glücklich das größte test auch gegen
diese bescheide
[Musik]
du kannst auch einfach deine zunge
rausstrecken wenn du zwiebeln schneidet
also das sollte jetzt nicht so schwer
sein
[Musik]
du musst die zwiebel kalt abwaschen
damit sie nicht brennen eine zivile mit
kaltem wasser abspülen
ich sehe noch nicht so ganz was das
helfen soll du gehst jetzt kann das
lenkrad oder war oder mit immer ich habe
auch gelesen dass ein dass es besser da
zu helfen soll
als ich bin sehr gespannt amt assist
hilft es wäre superschön war dieser teil
okay das jetzt hier entweder meine augen
haben sich jetzt gerade dran gewöhnt er
trägt gleichzeitig auch ein bisschen
gekostet abgesehen von meinem tränen am
anfang hat es wirklich sehr gut
funktioniert ich liebe in viereinhalb
stunden ins gefrierfach legen oder unter
wasser schneiden
na dann wollen wir das gute stück doch
mal raus holen die sauberkeit die sehr
kalte zwiebel in der hand gehabt
rationieren
ich würde mal sagen das ist mein live
aid heckmann selber zwiebel nicht
einfach in der gefriertruhe aufbewahren
oder an die dann frieren sie 100
platziert wollt ihr das vielleicht in
einer zweiten folge sehen wir liefern 8
es wirkt wenn beim zwiebelschneiden ein
paar kerzen daneben stellt die lassen
die dämpfe verdunsten die eine zum
weinen bringen
[Musik]
jesus maria josef und pater gottes im
himmel
wir opfern diese zwiebeln für die tische
ein live act ist es schon mal denn die
ganzen duftkerzen vertreiben gerade
diese züge geruch ruhe in frieden
wieso habe ich diesen leine genommen
gibt mich auch die kerzen jüngste mal
eine träne mich bekommen
kleiner tipp nimmt zum zwiebelschneiden
ein kleines dünnes und scharfes
küchenmesser was mir treu gedient doch
nun kommt ein schlankerer dünnerer
jüngerer nachfolger es nobis like
showbusiness zu beschaffen das soll
tatsächlich helfen bei zwiebeln wenn sie
nicht zu zerquetschen von einem stumpfen
messer handlicher
[Musik]
tränen frei ich gegen brennende augen
blicken zwiebeln hätten kaugummis kauen
ich bin wirklich gespannt was kaum jetzt
bringen soll beim zwiebelschneiden das
gute bio kaugummi und ich meine auch
beim fliegen will ist keine beim
zwiebelschneiden nicht verkehrt sein
sondern vielleicht den sound ein
bisschen 100 drehen damit die leute
nicht kotzen am ende dieser mama da hat
nichts gebracht denn du leitbetrieben
schneiden willst und auf eine art die
nicht so tränen erregend ist gibt es
dazu von gordon ramsay eine gute
variante
du bist ein nichts
ein höchst martin kaßler
biocel paskov as die tränen in die augen
treibt dann kriegst du demnächst tun
dass es gehört ja richtig so nach einer
was richtig in deinem leben durch 1
zwiebel somit schneidig dich für ein
schwachkopf lasst mich doch wie mit
fonds oder queen's ja der träger
geholfen
ich war schläft nicht
[Musik]
ich würde mal sagen das fazit von diesem
video ist schreibt eure zwiebeln speck
bine pöhner nur ohne alles ich hoffe ich
komme da hat eure zwiebel gelüste
befriedigen und in beim nächsten mal
wenn ich wieder was koche werde ich
definitiv die taucherbrille ansetzen
oder meine anschreiben sowie kommen und
damit sind wir schon am ende des videos
angekommen gibt mir einen daumen nach
oben wenn ihr auf jeden fall einem
zweiten teil sehen wollt oder vielleicht
was ganz verrücktes mit knoblauch oder
charlotten oder schreibt mir einfach mal
eure ganz persönlichen küchen live hacks
vielleicht mache ich ein video in dem
ich sie ausprobieren und wir werden alle
was dazu aber bitte nicht diese
komischen instagram du kannst das und
dann packen wir das in betrieb waren
also so richtige leitfähigen hier kennt
und seit jahren anwendet und hier sind
noch zwei weitere videos vergesst nicht
einen kanal zu abonnieren und aktiviert
die glocke um kein neues video zu
verpassen und ich mache jetzt definitiv
eine schöne gut
[Musik]